Elijah moved to Florida
originally I moved from Omaha to
California about four years ago I live
in California for about three years I
had kind of friends there and then I've
got more friends in Miami So eventually
moved from California to Miami to join
those friends here why save that taxes
though I mean if you really want to give
the money back it should send a better
idea to live in California or New York
where you pay more taxes um I don't
really care much about taxes there are
certain social programs that I would
want funded and if you have to raise
taxes to fund those that's fine but I
don't think there's anything like
intrinsically good about paying taxes or
not paying taxes it's just a matter of
whether or not the the programs that you
want are getting funded I guess so it
you don't see anything intrinsically
good whether you pay taxes or you don't
pay taxes um not not really so unpacked
though what do you mean by that
um I feel like
[Music]
sorry let me know if I'm rambling too
much but um oftentimes people get
attached to processes instead of
outcomes yeah right uh so a really good
example uh might be housing people right
we want houses for more people but
people will look at a process like we'll
say rent control and that becomes
inexorably tied to the outcome where
it's if you support rent control you
support housing people if you're opposed
to rent control you're opposed to
housing people but sometimes that
process is not like a good process so
it's hard for people to back away from
it because in their mind like you have
to support this thing well it's not even
getting us to our end goal and I view
taxation the same way taxation is like a
tool it's not good or bad to pay taxes
or not pay taxes it's just like a tool
that we use to fund the government and
then the real fight should be what do we
want the government to be doing and then
assuming that we've got like these
Services you know conservatives tend to
want less liberals or left-leaning
people tend to want more uh considering
the services that we've got provided by
the government we raise enough uh money
and taxes to fund those Services that's
how I do it I just there's not like a so
what do you think we're wasting money
what do you think we should be investing
more money like what do you think taxes
should go to where are we wasting it
um where are we wasting it man I don't
know there's probably a ton of different
areas I imagine that everybody's wasted
money everywhere um I feel like
everybody always says that I'm gonna go
line by line and then when they get an
office they're like no [ __ ] that
um in terms of where we should invest
um I'm begging like preventative stuff
or like investing for the future so I
think big Investments and education and
they're important I don't know if you
like that one
um and then investments in like things
where we know we can save money so that
move to expand the IRS I thought that
was a good one because that's a way to
raise money for the federal government
um investments in um
things like providing contraception wait
but expanding the IRS as a way to raise
money for the government
um yeah my understanding is that the IRS
knows that there's a lot of money out
there but they don't have the agents to
work all the files so expanding the IRS
is one of the few ways where the
government can increase its expenditure
on some government employees but raise
more money for the government but you
did see that that was going to cost the
little guy more because it's the little
guys that they go after more
um like expanding their right right now
they're they're devoting their resources
more towards the big guys because they
know that that's that's got the the
value added right there they expand
their agency then they can go after the
little guys the the guys that get taken
out by a pothole no
um when you're a little guy your taxes
are like the last thing that you're
worried about in my personal opinion um
generally speaking well if you look at
any I mean you can look at all the
advertising for hey if you're if you're
in debt and you owe the IRS we will help
you the advertising says there are a lot
of people who need to Avail themselves
at that service sure and also on our
block will charge you 200 to fill out
like your W-2s I mean people can
advertise for certain things I'm just
saying that
um I I don't think that the IRS is like
targeting poor people now I don't think
that's true I know some people were
worried because like
um there are certain uh apps like venmo
and cash app that might have been flying
under the radar um I don't think they
issue I don't know if they issue 109
case like PayPal does but like maybe for
things like that but for the most part
expanding the IRS should help them go
after the money that they know is either
I don't think they're targeting uh poor
people if you want to talk about
targeting poor people I do agree that
that's not a good thing however pretty
sure it was conservatives that pushed
for
um if you are if you get the Earned
Income Tax Credit the ITC I believe that
there is a mandatory like 10 audit on
those people as a contingency to make
sure that they're not scamming the
government or something with their taxes
so I would agree that that's a waste of
money
um in terms of where the IRS is focusing
on uh just because of the that mandatory
audit rate but aside from that I don't
think expanding the IRS is them just
going after little guys because I don't
think he raised very much money doing
that if you earn 30 or 40 000 a year
um I don't even know what the average
federal tax liability is for somebody
like that it's probably pretty low very
low if not very low it might be nothing
yeah yeah below 10 for sure I suppose it
depends on how you define the little guy
that throws just how we Define a little
guy before I got into um streaming I did
carpet cleaning um which sucked balls so
for me little guys like 24 30 000 a year
that's that's a little guy for me if you
guys are thinking like 80 90 100 000
years little guys do you know what
percentage of America makes more than a
hundred grand
um I want to say three percent close
what is it what do you think what it is
I don't know you know the number 20 15
is it 15 15 makes more than than six
feet hold on is that 15 of earners or 50
of households that's a good that's a
good caveat right there I think it is
earners okay yeah let's dive at one
point like what do you need to be like
the top one percent earner and I think
it's like 300K it's like 450 or maybe
say something in that regard all right
uh 15 of this country making over 50 of
workers that sounds like a lot to me
there's a lot of wealth in this nation
or it's just not a lot of money anymore
as it used to and you know where maybe a
hundred thousand is not a lot of money
today used to be a big deal
in the 80s and the 90s so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]